There's already a
mile of
wound,
right? Okay okay, there is a difference in votes.
God God,
you come out once, I couldn't understand, I'll call, let's
be ready, at least I was
ready, I guess 50 kg.
man So HD it's so hard no
food right
we're in the air it's lean
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up I guess it's coming
92 opened 52.8 sure This is possible point
started to drop in what he left at 85 or what will he do
on other channels for 6 years or something
I'm smoking
What  Let me do it, will you go
with the camera,
so if you're going there, I'll go too
[Music]
okay
okay we
need to get closer Arda Hacım I
'm making a transition
or
returning
Fatih Cesur
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Applause]
Hello
[Music]
Goodbye
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music
] [Music] [Music
] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
in one  There are 40 minutes 35 minutes
one has 150 minutes
okay
internet
[Applause]
shouting a lot du
[Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gazi Where are you  Niyazi
[Applause]
[Music]
put [
Applause]
in [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music
]
[Music]
[Applause]
Allah  Allahu akbar
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [
Applause
]
[Applause]
what a beauty I thought where did it come from
their shops are working hard
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Music] [Music
] [
Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
]
[Music]
95.8 percent of ballot boxes opened according to unofficial figures
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan
[Applause  ]
Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu 47.7
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
lira
We thank the silent world [Music] [Applause] free sites
[Applause]
[Music] There
should be a race in politics,
nation's
business
[Music]
you are
gaybayı Kemali, you should retire now
[Music] [
Music]
Our nation
has taken care of its crescent and star flag,
our nation
is finished, our nation
said that you will never be able to give these two, and
our nation
This time to Recep Tayyip Erdoğan
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]  ]
[Music] is on the
way
like a man.
You did not leave our President Recep Tayyip Erdogan alone, we stand
firm and determined today as we did when we
thank us once again.
Turkey has won 5 million today
and
lost after those years
Azer
[Music]  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
is bliss
[Applause] [
Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
after May 14th today,
despite the pain they suffered with their customs
snowed insulted insulted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Applause] [Music]
[Music]
if not, it's just a
lie
[Music]  ] [
Music]
[Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
Number of chests opened
96.89%
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan 52.23%
[  Music]
Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu 47.77
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music] [
Music]
let the innocent sing their songs Turkey is
not half a hundred Right now [
Music]
what did he say to those who want to bury myself  there is
no difference,
we are not afraid, we are not
afraid of the dark night We are not afraid of the oppressor Your right to freedom From eternity, not
tomorrow, Let the
oppressed sing their
songs with their handsome [Music] Let the
oppressed people sing
their songs.  century is
not tomorrow Right now
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] the
body dies and rots, look at the soul, see
who it walks with, you
let the ferris wheels turn,
look towards the truth and you
[Music] [Music
]
Even if it's snow and winter
[Music] Your
path  The end
[Music]
I will be crazy who pulls
[Music] back,
what will happen, we will
all
be Turkey together
[Music]
let's die like men [
Music] [
Music]
[Music] the
secret is
shocking too, my
friend,
Recep Tayyip  Erdogan
[Music]
[Music] there is
no
turning from the road,
in the
prayers of mothers, in the prayer of the mothers, Recep Tayyip in his wife
is here, in his prayer,
Recep Tayyip Erdogan in
the night
[Music] [
Music]
will go the way [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
You are ours  You Don't Know the Mountains, Smile,
Grizzly, even if the smoke goes down, see it
every week, every week of the holiday, every day, even if you
go to the highlands, you don't know, you don't know, when our people find love, they will come close to you, and the
molds will not show the truth, maybe the
veils of the heart will be removed and the
veils of the heart will be ripped, here are
the lovers, here is
our President Recep Tayyip Erdogan.
Here are those who decided to walk towards a brighter future Thank you Istanbul Thank you
Turkey
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music
]
Which one is like Aslan Which
man this road is a tough one
[Music] the
road is from
action
[Music]
Which one is like a lion, which one
has a very tough [Music] road.  It was
written as the
namerdin water Bulanık Akar
floods the places where it flows, and
Kakar without benevolence
was writing us for such a needy action.
We want a strong voice from you and we want to greet the people of those regions whose hearts are in pain.
Are we ready
Adana
Adıyaman
Diyarbakır
Elazığ
Gaziantep
Hatay
Kahramanmaraş Malatya
Osmaniye
Şanlıurfa
who wrote the epic Turkey
thank you
[Applause] [
Music] The
quiet is the free voice of the world;
Our President, Recep Tayyip Erdogan, who devoted his life to his nation, and our
beloved nation, who does not know any Master other than the nation that derives its strength from the nation, and our beloved nation, we
thank
you
all [Music] [Music]
Can we see the hands first so that our members of the press can get a good view from here, let's see your
white hands that made history today,
thank you very much.
Now, we
want to see the mobile
phone lights once again.
Today, Turkey is illuminated once again with your white hands.
[Music] You
look amazing Really
Because this beloved nation
deserves the best and the most beautiful of everything
Because you are the people who are in love with our flag with crescent and star,
We thank you all very much today
everybody won Turkey won nobody
lost 85 million won
[Music] [
Music]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Music] rejoice, even if we
die with Mehmet's heads high, rejoice, even if we come back, don't think that
this wheel will remain on the mound
Tomorrow is certainly ours, of course it
is ours.
today Turkey said that today Turkey will walk in Yiğit
[Music]
I have witnessed around Turkey No Turkey Thank
you to Turkey who has taken care of Erdogan [
Music]
Who is the smoke [
From the smoke then [
Music]
Which is the
state of the world [Music]  About
[Music]
Which one is
like Aslan, which one is a real man A tough
road, the state of the world,
or nothing to Turkey, there is no other Derman, there
is no other Erdogan to Turkey, the
rally of Turkey [Music] in the Atatürk Airport national garden in Istanbul 1 million 700 thousand
The Boutique that we realized with the participation of us was
almost the herald of today, and here
we are, thanking all turkey for re-electing our president, our president, Recep Tayyip Erdoğan, with the support and prayers of our nation
[Music] [
Applause]
let's see the flags
[Music] [Music] [
Music
]
[Music]  ]
catapan to the nation, the mountain is visible to the disgrace
[Music]
stop is the owner of justice
katap
[Music]
moment
Erdogan Aslan bye-bye
[Music] [
Music]
water Silver
stone gold
look like heaven
How can one not be proud of all history and epic,
this is the Land of Roses, High Hearts
Its land is neither worthy of a fight, nor a fight.
Love falls on us. Peace, these loves are ours,
these epics are ours, these people are ours,
this country, we are all of us, the
star
has no name, let your
name be today. Today, the 100 Year of Turkey
begins. Your eyes, enlightened young people. The
100 Year of Turkey is
the project of our President with your inspiration and this
You are the ones who will glorify the country in its centennial year,
because let's see the hands of the youth.
Young
people, Mashallah, the
number of ballot boxes opened according to unofficial results is
98.6 percent.
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan 52.12
Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu
47.88 [
Music] [
Music]
[Music] We
saw what was at the beginning Shadows changed balances
e
[Music] The
Mountain of Hope was kneaded, we stood up and stood up
again, we exist with
balloons Our love is based, both local and
national
direction is certain,
wrong, never accidentally
You said that word, you said to our
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan, the architect of our country's bright future, you
said no stop, no stop, no stop, no stop, no stop, keep going, and we
thank Istanbul and all of turkey
[Music]
Are we ready, it's
time for the lovers to meet
[Music]
[  Applause] There
is a ship pulled from the horizon. There is a ship that has been pulled from the horizon. The
obstacles to the surging waves are narrow, they
said to its captain, Erdogan
The longed is coming, the expected is coming The
good son of Anatolia is coming
Our President Recep Tayyip Erdoğan is
coming
[Applause] [
Music]
Yes, let's see the flags, let's see the
flags, let's see the flags,
Bayraktar
[Music  ] Those who
interfere with my religion I
wish those who stretch my tongue We wish there is no difference to us We are not
afraid of the dark night We are not afraid of the dark night We are the right of freedom from eternity,
not tomorrow,
always be
happy O Sun
[Music] O the light
among us,
lies escape from the truth The
sun shines bright around you even though it is alone
You walk, Chief of
Crows  Eagles Fly High
[Applause] Let the
sky fill the lights, let the clouds
sing, their songs are
coming The good son of Anatolia
is coming, the
loud voice of the innocents of the world is
coming The free voice of the silent world
[Music] It's
OK, he's coming, let's turn on the phone lights like a man,
Recep Tayyip Erdoğan,
phone
lights, all the lights
[  Applause]
Our President Recep Tayyip Erdoğan and
his wife, Doğan and his brothers,
greet each other with love
[Applause] [
Music] [Music]
for Turkey, he
always sings it [
Music]
this love is immortal in everyone's language
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[  Clap]
[Music] Those who do
n't hear ask
[Applause]
Lara
we watch it I love it I love it
I love it
We continue with Istanbul
[Applause]
[Music]
today
[Applause] is
another limited
Üsküdar is another
and Istanbul is another
Dear case and my fellow travellers,
I greet you with my heartfelt feelings and respectfully and
affectionately.  [
Music] I would like to express my gratitude to my nation for making the Day of democracy live [Music] I would like to
thank all my citizens who showed their will for the future of themselves and their children by going to the polls
[Applause] [
Applause]
all the members of our organization, our
women's and youth branches, our poll
observers, our campaign team of everyone who voluntarily
contributed to the smooth running of the election.
I
congratulate our women I
congratulate our young people
and I
congratulate all my brothers and sisters who gave their hearts to the AK Party cause I would like to
thank everyone who ran to the ballot box with especially high vote rates compared to the second round.  I would like to
thank each and every member of our nation who conveyed the message
inshallah
[Applause]
I hope we
will be worthy of your trust. We
will be worthy as we are worthy of 21 years.
What did I say Sunday
[Applause] We
said that this love does not end here,
now look, they say Mr. Kemal.
[Applause]
We always have this  We said that a blessed march would not be incomplete
We always said that those who serve
do not suffer defeat
[Applause]
We said that we are entrusted to Turkey
[Applause],
if you want, we can declare a third Mr.By.
Just as Iron meets fire and turns into Steel,
your willpower
has become Turkey's unbreakable and unbreakable stainless power at the ballot box.
Now
look
here, my brothers and sisters, I
am an accountant for Turkey.
The number of deputies of the CHP was 169 in this election,
but it
gave rental deputies to certain parties that did not have even one percent of the vote in total, how many 40.
What happened, now it
has dropped to 129 CHP
accountant either
knows these things very well,
and
thus,
because of the deputies he lost  We
say that the winner of both the 14 May and 28
May elections is
all of our 85 million citizens,
but I said something else,
remember,
we said that we will win so much that no one
will lose.
We opened the door of the century of Turkey, but we
opened it together, we have
realized the dreams and excitements of all segments of our nation, from men to women, from the young to the elderly, from employees to retirees,
together we have raised the hopes of our friends whose hearts and eyes are turned towards us.
I hope that our every struggle from now on again,
look at the area you see,
now it's amazing, my daughter and the history of the Square.  history has written
[Applause]
As an Istanbul, a person from Üsküdar with a ragged hair, what can I say, I
thank God for giving me fellow travelers like you,
we will celebrate all our victories together with you again.
Are we ready to win both Istanbul and Istanbul in the local elections? Then we will
not stop, we will work hard, I
said from the police,
how many
citizens do I have?  This is the
biggest message of today's elections. This is the biggest message of today's elections. The
election results
have shown once again that we
cannot covet the gains of this country.
they say,
announce if necessary, invite us. We
will come right now
Because
Qatar seeks this victory with us both in the west and in the gulf, does it
share happiness as well, no one
can extend a hand to the rights and freedoms of our people,
no one can look down on our nation and
insult our people, they can't insult our
youth into their own bottomless darkness.
No one can drag us, no one Turkey can wave a finger, from the
terrorist organization to the dark
places.
[Applause] is
this HDP lgbt is
this the good party lgbt There
are some little guys next to him Are they lgbt too Are they lgbt too Can lgbt
infiltrate the AK Party can lgbt infiltrate
MHP
can it fit in with other members of the People's alliance
[Applause]
Don't forget
Yunus, we are always reborn
As those of us say, every choice is
a rebirth for us,
family is sacred to us,
no one can speak out against the family.
Violence against women is forbidden in us,
no one can resort to it,
and we
will do whatever we promised to our nation [Applause] We will stick to our principle of not making any promises that you can't keep.
Now I'm on my way to Ankara with feelings,
this time we are making a change,
I hope
we will make the balcony speech from the complex, we
will call out to the whole world from the complex [
Applause] will you let us
shout, let's all Turkey hear
Üsküdar will do this, let's
raise their hands
[Applause] on
this occasion,
thank you very much to us and my brothers.  I believe they
went to the tent cities in containers and
cast their votes with a big ferry May God be pleased with them May God
protect them from the worst
As you said, Inshallah, within a year, we will
deal with permanent residences Are we
ready,
one nation, one
flag, one homeland, one
state, we will be
one, we will be
big, we will be alive,
we will be brothers, we
will all be Turkey together
[Applause]
Thanks Istanbul
Are you ready Ankara We are coming to you
[Music]
today Turkey won today the world's
oppressed have won
today
Azerbaijan won today Karabakh won
Are you
[Music]
God to the
last moments
we love him I love him very much I
love
[Music]
very much [
Music]
We love
Üsküdar Thank
you, stay, God bless
[Applause]
Thank you Istanbul is coming to you,
ready for Ankara  Do you
[Applause]
thank you very much, we thank you very much to our precious belongings from
Üsküdar, who embraced our president with great enthusiasm,
yes,
we send greetings to Ankara from here Wait for us, we
are coming to Ankara [
Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
Thanks Ancients
Thanks Istanbul Thanks Turkey
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [Music]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Music] [Applause] [Music] [Music
]
[Applause] [Music] [Music] [
Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[
[Music  ]
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause] [Music]
[
Applause]
[Music] [
Clap]
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Applause] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]